Hi, welcome back. In the last session,
we started our discussion of alternative
investments. Investments that are
alternative to the traditional stocks
and bonds and financial assets that so
much of investing is centered on. We
focused on real estate as the largest
alternative investment class. In this
session, I want to focus on collectibles
and trophy assets. Let's start with
collectibles. What is it that makes for
a collectible? The first feature they
have is they don't have cash flows. You
don't hold you don't get any cash flows
while you hold them, but their price
might still go up. You're saying, why
would people pay a price for something
that doesn't deliver cash flows? It
could be because it's scarce, but
scarcity alone doesn't make for a
collectible. The people holding it get
some kind of utility from holding it.
And finally, individual perceptions
about whether this this collectible will
hold value will continue to drive the
price. So investments that don't deliver
cash flows but have some other property
that makes them attractive to buyers are
collectibles.
Collectibles can only be priced. We
talked about why earlier without the
cash flows they cannot be valued. So the
notion that you know and we'll talk
about gold and artwork is a picasso
undervalued overvalued. You can't answer
the question. It can be underpriced or
overpriced. They can be only priced. But
the pricing process can be tricky for
the following reasons. Remember, to
price something, you got to find other
things just like it and see what people
are paying for it. With stocks, we
talked about finding other stocks just
like the stock you're looking at. With
real estate, we look for other
properties just like ours and see what
people are paying for it. That's much
more difficult to do with collectibles
because finding something comparable can
be really difficult to do. In fact, in
um you know, if you have a Picasso and
you say, "I want to price the Picasso,
it's not easy to find out the Picassos
instantly." Which brings me to the
second point, which is even if there are
25 Picassos out there, most don't get
bought or sold on a yearly basis or even
every decade. They're not that liquid
and the market is not public. Many
transactions are private and you don't
get to observe the price. And finally,
if you want to control for differences,
how the heck do you do that with a
collectible? Again, let's stay with the
Picasso example example. You have three
Picassos. What are the differences? You
would control for the size of the
canvas. That sounds like a weird thing
to control for. So, you can already see
the challenge in pricing collectibles.
So, in this session, I want to focus in
on some collectibles. Let's start with
artwork, right? It used Picassos
repeatedly in the in the as as my
example. But Picasso is just part of a
much broader class of art world
stretching back in time. Until very
recently, probably until about 30 years
ago, people had no idea whether art made
money or not. You knew that very wealthy
people owned art and sometimes that
artwork went up in price. But starting
about 30 years ago, you started to see
indices that track the returns in
artwork. Let me tell you though, these
indices are not perfect. They're based
on transactions and often you got to you
got to classify artwork based on whether
it's from the the Middle Ages, more
recent into different types, you know,
impressionist and then look at
transactions and mark up prices based on
that. But to the extent that you believe
these returns, here's what you see. In
the periods that people have looked at
artwork, and I have the data only
through 2010, artwork has lagged returns
on stocks, it's neither here nor there
because the sales pitch for artwork is
not that you will earn higher returns
than you will on stocks, but like real
estate, it's that it's not correlated
with what happens on stocks. So if
you're you have the bulk of your wealth
in stocks, maybe buying some fine art
can help you hedge some of that risk
because that fine art might go up in
price in periods where stocks are down.
Now, of course, let's focus in even if
you're convinced by that data on
correlation on why artwork can be a
challenging add-on for most of us. As I
said, it's not a very liquid market,
very few transactions. So it's very
difficult to get the pricing right.
Second is said even if you have the same
artist you know comparing know what
people pay across different artwork can
be tough to do and with artwork there's
a very real possibility that if you
don't know what you're doing you will be
scammed because there's a possibility of
forgery and fraud. I'll be quite honest,
I can't tell a
you know some impressionist who who
looks like a Monet and I would be a
terrible buyer of artwork if I did not
have some help. You're saying well I can
hire an expert. You can but remember
that's going to cost you. So you have
expert appraisers. The transactions cost
that comes often comes from the fact
that you need to get artwork priced and
expert appraisers are needed for that.
So you look at the big agencies, Suddies
for instance, that sells artwork. You're
going to leave a substantial amount of
the price behind. There's a big
transactions cost involved. So when you
look at artwork, here are the things I
would suggest you think about it. If
you're thinking about adding artwork to
your portfolio, first recognize you will
be spending substantially more time
doing research, collecting specialized
knowledge if you want artwork to be part
of your portfolio. Now you I've talked
about paintings but art you know you
could expand collectibles to look at
baseball cards and that's a lot of
research you would need to do if that is
the place you want to put your money
much higher transactions cost be ready
for them. But my advice most of all with
artwork or baseball cards or any other
collectibles is buy them because you
enjoy them. The emotional dividend part.
If you buy Picassos and you keep them
locked up in a closet I don't think this
is a great investment. But if you buy
Picassos, you leave them hanging on the
wall and you enjoy that Picasso every
time you walk by it. That's emotional
dividend.
And sometimes you will be fooled. Even
the very best art collectors, and you've
probably read stories about this, have
been fooled by fakes and scams. So, can
artwork belong in your portfolio? Yes.
But walk in with open eyes.
Let's move on to the second and perhaps
the longest standing collectible known
to man, gold. You go back to ancient
times, you see stories about how gold
was held by people because they thought
it had value. So the notion that gold is
precious is not just in the last few
centuries. It's been essentially for as
long as you have human history.
And early on it should be it should be
recognized that gold preceded paper
currencies. And many of the governments
that had issued paper currency ran into
a problem which is people didn't want to
hold paper currency because they didn't
trust governments. So you know how
governments got them to trust them? By
linking the paper currency to gold. The
gold standard very simply came into
place because that was the way
governments got people to hold on to
paper currency. And in a true gold
standard they allowed people to bring
the paper currency in and convert it
back to gold if they didn't trust the
government. Um the
the 1800 in the 1700s the the US
government during the 1800s in fact both
the the the English government and the
US government initially made their
currencies convertible into both gold
and silver but both screwed up by
setting the ratio of gold to silver too
low in other words you needed too many
too few units of silver to get gold so
silver got you know and this is the
basis of Gresham's law which is good bad
money drives out good money. What
happened was people brought in all their
silver convert to gold. The gold
standard but the gold standard know
while it became you know the the central
theme for paper currencies in the 1800s
ran into two tens two two events that
made it kind of fall apart. The first
was the first world war. You're saying
what do world wars have to do with the
gold standard? Well the world wars
governments had to spend money on
weapons. They didn't have enough paper
currency to do it as long as they stayed
connected to gold. So many governments
broke the link between their currencies
and gold because they needed to print
more money.
The US kind of hung in there with the
gold standard until the Great
Depression. In fact, there are some
people who argue that the constraints of
the gold standard made the depression
greater. I mean, that's debatable, but
it's it's and so after the go after the
Great Depression, the US stayed on the
gold standard but didn't allow
individuals to convert their currencies
into gold effectively undercutting one
of the dimensions of the gold standard.
Then the second world war and emerging
from the second world war the US was the
dominant global economy and the US
dollar became the standin for gold in in
fact instead of making their currencies
convertible into gold other currencies
made themselves convertible into the US
dollar. The reason that worked though is
the US still connected the US dollar to
gold until you get to the early 70s
where even that linkage was broken. So
gold has been around longer than paper
currencies and you can see its basis. So
let's start with the with a very simple
question. How good an investment is
gold? And the answer is not very good.
In fact, if you look at pure statistics,
your question is going to be why would
anybody hold gold? So in this table I've
compared the returns the annual returns
you'd have made on gold versus stocks
and looking from 1984 through 2024 and
you're saying why are you going back
only to the to 1984 until 1971 gold
prices because they were linked to the
US dollar really didn't I didn't reflect
a demand supply set price it was set by
governments for conversion rates so it's
only since the 70s that you had gold
prices that are based on demand and
supply that we can use to Compute
returns the last 40 years annual returns
on gold have been about 5 1.5%.
Stocks 11.7%.
It's true if you move it back to 1980
and get started there in 1979 gold does
a little better but overall gold lags
stocks in terms of returns and it
actually has a slightly higher standard
deviation. If you pause right there and
say why would you ever invest in
something that has a lower average
return and a higher standard deviation.
Let's hold on because if you stayed with
the just these numbers, here's how it
would pay off. A $100 invested in gold
in 1984 would be worth $8.48 today. The
same $100 invested in stocks in ' 84
would have been worth $8,300 at the end
of 2024. And you can look across time
how much of a price you'd have paid
putting your money in gold. So now let's
look at what makes gold essentially
stand up. If you look at gold, it's not
a great currency, right? It's true.
There have been gold coins over time,
but it it's it's, you know, can you
imagine going into a Starbucks and
trying to pay with gold? It's very
difficult to get in fine enough units to
be able to pay for most of the things.
It's not a great currency. It is true
that gold has used as a commodity
starting with fillings. You remember
tooth fillings used to be gold, jewelry,
even in some tools where you need
essentially there is a use as a
commodity but it's as a collectible that
gold is stood out while you hold gold
you don't get cash flows
no but to the extent that governments
and banks and individuals attach a value
people hold gold. So let's ask the
question is it a good collectible and in
the process you can develop a framework
for looking at any collectible first it
is scarce why it is a natural resource
at the end of 2025 it's estimated nobody
knows for sure there are 244,000 metric
tons of gold in the world it's true
people are still extracting gold from
the ground but only about 3,000 tons
were added to that mix in 2024 and
that's a typical year there's not that
much gold being added and there's only
so much gold left under the ground.
That puts it in a sweet spot. In what
way? You don't want something for a good
collectible. You want you don't want
something that's so scarce that the
prices and the price is so skyhigh that
people can't hold it. So something like
platinum doesn't work. It's too scarce.
And something which is much more
plentiful is not going to work because
the price will drop very quickly. So
scarcity, gold has it. Gold also has
durability. If you look at the elements
and you wonder why people pick gold as
their instrument for putting for holding
as a collectible, it is durable. It's
very difficult to destroy gold. You can
melt it. You can shape it into things.
It's chemically stable. It's it's
malleable. So, you can make it into into
different things and store it. And it
doesn't oxidize or corrode. It has
physical properties that make it durable
and it's desirable. There's something
about gold that exerts a hold on
humanity. Think of all the fables,
right? The Greek myth of Midas, the king
who everything he touched on turn to
gold. El Dorado, the city in um
supposedly in South America that was
built of gold that actually create
changed history, right? Because the
Spanish crossed an ocean to colonize
South America
gold. So gold is a good collectible and
it's collectible and and and its allure
comes from all of those features. So
when you look at other collectibles like
baseball cards, pass them through the
same list. Is it scarce? Is it durable?
Is it desirable? So let's look at gold
prices from 63 to 2025 to see if we can
crack the code for what makes gold an
attractive add-on to to a portfolio or
not. So in this graph I have the gold
price by year from 1963 to 2025. So you
can see the red line but I've also
computed what I call the inflation
adjusted price of gold. And for much of
this table you can see the inflation
adjusted price of gold really kind of
stuck in it was stuck in in a quagmire.
It's only in 2025 that it's kind of
popped through the roof. But for and we
you know there's a theory out there that
in the long term gold prices increase at
the inflation rate. We'll come back and
look at whether that's true. But you can
see that the gold price over time has
gone up. And in fact, let's focus in on
what it is that drives the gold price up
or down. Because there have been periods
where gold prices have gone down.
You know, one way to think about um you
know, precious metals in general and
gold specifically is to look at three
factors. One is inflation and how it
plays out in gold. The second is and
there is a story of gold being the um
something you invest in when you're
scared scared of political crisis,
economic crisis. And there's a third
story which is when real interest rates
become low. This is what you make net of
inflation by investing in bonds. When
real interest rates become low, gold
becomes more attractive because you pay
a lower price for holding gold. Remember
gold has no cash flows. If real interest
rates are high, you give up more by
holding gold. And there should be so
let's say in fact those factors explain
gold first graph I have is the
percentage change in gold price every
year was the inflation rate you can see
the very strong connection the 70s but
across this the overall time period the
link between gold and inflation contrary
to conventional wisdom is fairly weak
the R squ is only 19% another way to
think of it 81% of the movement in gold
prices on a year-to-year basis have
nothing to do with inflation, but there
is a link. Every 1% increase in the
inflation rate creates a 3.92% increase
in gold with a standard error.
But if you focus in by decade, you're
going to see why gold might be a better
inflation hedge than that 18 or 19% R
squar would suggest. This is a slightly
modified version of the investment
returns by decade I showed you in the
real estate section where I've moved
everything by a year to and made it a
more up to- date through 2025.
So as I said between 31 and 60 I've not
even tried to compute the return on gold
because it was linked to the dollar. It
looked like a it looks like a flat line.
Starting in the 60s I'm I can compute an
annual return and in most periods gold
lags stocks and even bonds but the 1970s
clearly things get blown out of the
water in a year which was which was not
a great in a decade which is not a great
decade for financial assets. gold at 38%
annual returns each year. But it was
also a period where unexpected inflation
was high. I want to draw a contrast
between expected inflation and
unexpected inflation.
When you invest in financial assets, you
build in an expectation of inflation
being 3% 5% 7%. When you build it in,
it's already priced in. Why? Because if
you expect inflation to be 5%, you set
interest rates at 7%, you're covered.
And you can say the same thing about
stocks. It's unexpected inflation that's
deadly for investors. What's unexpected
inflation? Let's go back to our example.
You thought inflation was going to be
5%. You set interest rates at 7%. And
you went home happy. But let's say the
actual inflation rate was 12%. You had
unexpected inflation of 7%. 12 - 5. As a
bond holder, you're badly hurt. And in
fact, unexpected decades when unexpected
inflation has been high. 1970s is the
most classic example have not been good
for financial assets. But gold deals
with unexpected inflation really well.
In fact, you could argue that when you
have unexpected inflation, people flee
paper paper currencies, they go into
gold. In fact, one reason, and this is
something we'll talk about more, that
gold has done so well in the last 5
years might be because unexpected
inflation again has been higher than
expected. 2022 was that breaking point
where inflation jumped above
expectations. So here's how I think
about gold and inflation. Gold is not a
great hedge against year-to-year
inflation if that inflation stays
moderate. So if inflation goes from 3 to
4% or 4 to 5% gold is not going to do
much for you. But if inflation jumps
from 3 to 8% 3 to 10%
gold is the place to be. That's the
basis for gold as a hedge against
inflation. Say, what about crisis? Now,
of course, we could go back in time and
isolate crisis. A 2008 was a crisis.
2020 was a crisis. But I think that's
hindsight. So, instead of doing that to
get a continuous measure of crisis, I
measured two risk premiums which you've
seen before. One is the equity risk
premium which measures whether equity
investors are in crisis. When they're in
crisis, the equity risk premium becomes
higher. and the BAA spread over the T-
bond rate again measure of you know
scare of worry in the bond market in
fact if you look at 2008 you can see how
those numbers spiked
and then I asked a question how do gold
prices
work with you know how do they move
relative to these measures because both
the equity risk and the bond default
spread then become measures measures of
crisis the R squar is close to zero so
you're saying that's terrible I thought
gold was a hedge against crisis. Again,
I would like to draw a distinction
between small crises and big crisis.
Just like I drew a distinction between
moderate inflation and hyperinflation.
Gold didn't do very well with moderate
inflation, did really well with
hyperinflation.
I'm going to make the same argument
about gold and crisis. If your crisis is
a run-of-the-mill crisis, and you can
use your own definition,
run-of-the-mill, gold is not going to be
the place to go. But if your crisis is
potentially catastrophic,
gold should then behave much better in
terms of responding to that. So as with
inflation, it's the big events, the
unexpected events, the potentially
catastrophic events that gold protects
you against. Finally, on real interest
rates, this actually has the highest R
squared when real interest rates are
low. And the way you measured real
estate, real interest rates in this
graph is until about 2000. And I
measured real interest rates by taking
the nominal interest rate, what you see
on a T- bond rate, subtracting out
inflation. Starting in 2000, I have
something I can use which is a
marketbased measure of real interest
rate in the form of a tips rate. This is
an inflation protect treasury bond. The
bottom line is no matter what definition
of real interest rates used, there is a
link. Low real interest rates are good
for gold prices. High real interest
rates are bad for gold prices. So in
summary, inflation crisis and real
interest rates and in summary again
while it's touted as a hedge against
inflation crisis, it's really a hedge
against hyperinflation and potentially
catastrophic crisis. Now things to think
about when you think about should I add
gold to my portfolio. It's really
insurance against extreme events rather
than small events that are more within
the bounds of what you'd expect to see
in an economy or markets.
So in October of 2025, gold prices it
soared above 4,000 for the first time in
history.
So if you look at gold prices, the
question is, you know, so in October
2025, the question is, is gold
overpriced? Well, one way to measure
that is look at at it relative to
inflation. In this graph, what I have is
the gold price divided by the CPI index
by year. And if you stop went all the
way through 2009 and you stopped there,
you can see why people really love this
measure, right? Until 2009,
gold and inflation seem to be kind of
locked at the head. In fact, a very
widely cited paper called the golden
dilemma uh to you know
it it's a book it's a paper which looked
at gold prices over time and concluded
that you know inflation is what drives
gold and if gold prices go above this
line then gold is overpriced. In fact
when the paper was written in 2013 the
argument is gold is overpriced it's
going to go back down. But if you look
at what's happened since, it initially
went down, but it's kind of sold. So the
there's clearly a break with a
historical relationship at least in the
last decade. Now, this might all
dissipate. Gold prices might go back to
where they should be, but that's
something to think about. The other
thing you can price gold against is the
other widely used precious metal, which
is silver. The median value for gold to
silver is about 57. gold prices at 57
times silver prices. And you can see
that, you know, kind of ups and downs
over time. But clearly, you've blown
through that again. In October of 2025,
gold prices were 85 times silver prices.
So, both against inflation and against
silver, you could make the argument gold
is overpriced. Now, before you get too
excited about that conclusion, know it's
based entirely on looking at history
that there's going to be mean reversion.
And the push back against that is maybe
something has shifted structurally that
can explain why gold prices should be
higher than they've been historically
both against inflation
and against silver. You may say what
could have shifted. I I don't know but I
I'll throw out four things that might
potentially explain why gold should be
priced higher than it's been
historically. The first is gold has
become much more liquid. There are more
ways you can buy gold. Instead of
actually having to buy physical gold
bars, now you can buy gold ETFs. There
are ways in which you can trade gold. So
the liquidity barriers have come down
and maybe that in remember gold is a is
a collectible demand and supply. So if
there's more demand because more people
can buy gold that could potentially push
up the price.
The second is remember gold competes
against paper currencies. Who issues
paper currencies? Central banks. And
what do we think about central banks?
Well, clearly a lot of people have lost
trust in central banks partly because of
what's happened since 2008. The view
that central banks have lost control of
the currency and are doing the bidding
of governments. True or not, there is
this lack of trust. And if you have a
lack of trust, that mistrust is going to
feed into a higher gold price. The third
is the global world order that we set
after the second world war that held for
several decades is starting to see
stress, right? To begin with, the US
dollar which was the center of the
universe and every other currency was
measured against it has become shakier
as a global currency and there's no
other currency right now ready to step
in the euro, the Chinese yuan, the
Indian rupee, they're not ready to be
global currencies and maybe they never
will. The the go gold is reasserting its
central role as hey you don't trust the
dollar. say you know relate back to us
we're the base and the other part of the
global economic order that's shifting is
you know for much of the last the second
half of the last century the US was the
center of the global economic system and
things revolved around it globalization
free trade the things we took for
granted that have all come under assault
in the last decade or so across the
world maybe that contributes to gold
prices going up as
Whatever the reason, before you jump out
there and sell short on gold because it
looks expensive, think about those
structural changes. So, here are the
ways gold may or may not fit in your
portfolio.
It there are people out there to whom
gold is the center of their portfolio,
right? What kinds of investors is that
the right thing to do? Remember, gold is
a hedge against extreme events,
hyperinflation,
catastrophes.
If you're an investor who believes that
the probability of those things have
increased significantly,
then you can make gold the center of
your portfolio. But remember, if you're
wrong, there will be a price to pay. You
would have earned a lower return than
those people who don't if that doesn't
happen. Okay? No catastrophe, no
hyperinflation. You could buy gold as
insurance. So, if you're worried about
these events, but you don't think
they're likely, but they could happen,
you could add it to a portfolio composed
of stocks and bonds to provide insurance
against those extreme events. As you
saw, gold is momentum up, momentum down.
It's you can trade it. And if you're
good at trading, who knows? You can end
up becoming rich trading gold by getting
in at the right time and getting out at
the right time. I don't own gold in my
portfolio, you know, but I do look at
gold prices because there's a signal
there that I can use. If you look at
that graph of gold prices rising,
there's at least a signal there that
inflation is not benign, that there's at
least a possibility that inflation could
become that there could be
hyperinflation, a crisis, and I've got
to factor into the types of stocks I buy
in even my asset allocation mix.
So, make a choice. There's no right
choice that fits all people. But you can
see how gold is something to think
about. So let's take each of these.
There's a core investment. You know,
when does it make sense? Most periods
you're going to lose money, but to the
extent that you distrust financial
assets. You think a catastrophic risk is
coming. Go for it. I'm not going to
contest you. There are people who look
down on gold bugs. People invest their
money in gold. I don't. I can understand
the draw. I know you you look paranoid,
but remember paranoia is not always
wrong if there what you're paranoid
about is on the horizon as insurance.
And you saw this. It's a weak hedge
against against small movements in
inflation and small crisis, but it's a
pretty good hedge against really
catastrophic events. Good to add to a
portfolio composed of financial assets,
especially if you're older and more risk
averse, right? It'll help you sleep
better at night. You could trade it, buy
and sell. I mean, think of how much
money you could have made if you could
call the low points and the high point
points. The only caveat I would add is
while you can make money riding
momentum, you got to get out at the
right time because if you stay in too
long, you'll lose all your profits.
Those people who made money on gold
between 77 and 79 lost it all over the
next five or 10 years because they
stayed too long in gold. It's a pricing
game. You've got to detect mood and
momentum. And in this case, that might
come to detecting how scared are people
of catastrophic risk because that might
be what causes those shifts. And
finally, as I said, gold is a signal.
Now, I don't even though I don't hold
gold, there is information in gold
prices that I should be using in
deciding my asset allocation mix. How
much in stocks, how much in bonds, how
much in bills, how much in real assets,
and also what types of stocks I might
buy. So if gold is signaling that higher
inflation is a very real probability, I
might buy more, you know, companies with
more pricing power because they can hold
their value better if things go bad.
The last set of collectibles I want to
talk about are trophy assets. You know,
trophy assets are assets. They have cash
flows. You can value them as assets, but
that value is completely washed up
because they have an emotional appeal
that makes them priced. they're going to
be de there's demanded supply that sets
a price well above the value and there's
no reason for convergence. So unlike a
stock where you say the value is much
much lower than the price the price has
to converge value with a trophy asset
that might not make them that might not
happen. What's a trophy asset? It first
it has to be unique. It has to be very
rare. We talked about scarcity. This has
to be really scarce. So as examples of
trophy assets, you can take properties
like the Ritz Carlton, right? Of itself,
you can buy it as real estate, but
you're also buying a legendary hotel. It
could be a publication like The
Economist publication. You can value it
as an asset, but it is the economy. It's
been around a couple of hundred years.
No. And one of the things I'm going to
talk about is trophy assets. It's
become, I think, the biggest class of
trophy assets, sporting franchises. You
want to buy Manchester United, it's
unique. A Premier League team is not
easy to get. It is scarce
and is often bought and sold for
non-financial reasons. Let's stay with
Manchester United. Why would you buy it?
Well, clearly you're not buying it
because you think you're going to make
money as a business. You're buying it
because you now own Manchester United.
And if you're a United fan, this is your
dream, right? Who hasn't dreamed about
owning the team that they cheer for
every year? It's hell for non-financial
reasons.
Now to to see how sports franchises
evolved over time, go back almost a
hundred years when the Rooney family in
Pittsburgh bought the Pittsburgh
Steelers for a pittance
and it is worth the pittance then,
right? It was a NFL team and there was
no NFL. So now American football was
just coming into being as a business.
And bought it for $2,500. They still own
it now. by by most estimates it's worth
4 billion but there is no way if you
value the Steelers as a business and you
can right it is a business you value it
as a business you're going to hit
anywhere close to 4 billion in fact I
will make that assertion you pick sports
franchises in some of the most widely
followed leagues football
in the US soccer in in Europe cricket in
India you can't get close to the pricing
so trophy assets to illustrate the
disconnect between pricing and operating
metrics. Take a look at this table. It
looks at some of the major sports
franchise leagues around the world. It
looks at the collective pricing. So
basically what you've looked what I've
looked at with the NFL is taken every
NFL team taking the estimates of pricing
and their estimates. The collective
pricing is 132.5 billion. Collectively
NFL teams had 16.1 billion in revenues,
4.7 billion operating profit. Then if
you look at net profit, even worse
numbers, they're trading at 8.23 times
revenue. So I know companies that do
that, but the companies that do that are
companies where the revenue growth is
going to be 30, 40, 50% a year. That's
not going to happen here. You look at
any traditional pricing metric and you
look at across the leagues, you see that
companies that trade trade at a pricing
that has lost connection with the
numbers. You're saying, then what
explains the pricing? If you get a
chance, take your favorite league and
take a look at who owns the franchises
in your league. I took the um in the in
this case, I took the the the NBA, the
the National Basketball League, and I
looked at the teams in the league and I
looked at the owners of the teams.
You're saying, where are we going with
this? Most of them are
worth hundreds of millions or even
billions and most of them made their
money elsewhere. They didn't make their
money in the sport. They made their
money as private equity investors in
hedge funds, in media. They're taking
money they made elsewhere
and they're buying a sports franchise.
Why? It's a toy. It's a very expensive
toy. But think of how much fun you can
have with this toy. No, I I remember
valuing the the Los Angeles Clippers a
decade ago when it when when NBA teams
was just taking off as franch as as um
as these um trophy assets. And I
remember valuing the the Clippers using
the best possible fundamentals I could
get and coming up with the value of
about $800 million. And Steve Armer, the
ex-CEO of Microsoft, had bought them for
two billion. And the only way I could
explain the 1.2 billion difference was
he's buying an expensive toy. And who
can blame him? In fact, if you've ever
seen a picture of Steve Balmer on the
sidelines of the Clippers, I would
strongly suggest if you haven't, take a
look and think of how much and and
you'll see how much fun he's having on
the sideline with his team and his
friends able to watch him watch his
team. Increasingly, sports franchises
are becoming wealthy people's toys. And
as long as the number of franchises is
fewer than the number of billionaires,
you're going to get this process play
out. There's no be no correction
happening. So, can you buy a sports
franchise? Well, if you're worth
hundreds of millions of billions, of
course you can. You need a lot of money.
But, you know, it is an illquid market
and you have to get a buyer to get rid
of it. And that buyer comes from a very
small subset of people. So, you got to
accept that this is a trade. You're
pricing it. And if you want to make
money on it, you got to find somebody
else who wants it even more than you do.
There is potentially a way you can make
money on it. Even if you're not worth a
billion or hundreds of millions, you
could pick a league which is still up
and coming. Remember the Roies bought
the Steelers when the NFL was not a
league, when the football was just
taking off. Maybe you can find the next
NFL. At the risk of being laughed at,
hey, what if you think pickle ball is
going to become the next great sport and
you find a professional pickle ball team
that you can buy for 500,000, the New
York pickle ballers or whatever they
decide to call themselves. If you're
right and pickle ball takes off, you
will be like the Roies. I know it's a
long shot, but if you truly enjoy
watching pickle ball and this is your
thing, hey, why not? You know, it might
be like buying a young
under the radar company. So, here's the
bottom line. Collectibles come in lots
of different forms and they all come
with limitations. They have no cash
flows and you hold them. They're often
illquid. They can be difficult to
authenticate.
But as a class, the reason you might be
attracted to them is because you might
enjoy being in that space. You might
enjoy fine art. You might enjoy baseball
cards. You might enjoy sports. you get
it and if you're willing to spend time
and research it, maybe you can have a
differential advantage over other
players and you get emotional dividends
while you hold them. Now, you can also
hold collectibles as a hedge, right? So,
if you are able to buy a piece of a
franchise and put it into your mostly
financial asset portfolio,
that could still pay off. So, it's a
choice to make and I hope you found the
session useful in making that choice.
Thank you very much for listening.